en vacances oui quand on est en vacances
on veut trouver des endroits pour se
loger on va dans des clubs dans des
hôtels et généralement on a quelques
galères alors on a fait un petit tableau
habituel de vos galères et on va
retrouver qui a un vécu quoi on y va
j'ai mangé du pain dans un château glace
et
ça ça veut rien dire
dans un château voyage à tous glace et
déjà il ya qu un barjot à la table c'est
deckers non je suis pas dupe ans
[Applaudissements]
j'ai
mangé pendant c'est là où là
j'avais réservé ça coûtait très cher
pour un réveillon de nouvel an 31
décembre dans un château et il
promettait à réveillon d'antan donc
quand on arrive devant les lions de lens
d'avant voilà exactement on a envie de
revenir non salée on doit laisser nos
voitures ont fait mouche en calèche
c'est génial ça coûte cher mais j'adore
j'adore on arrive dans l'aliment salle
du château il fait très très très très
froid doit faire 8 9 degrés air et tout
a été de cet ordre là c'était un manoir
complètement hanté c'était la maison
d'un des ventes vous faisait très froid
et le fameux repas et bas comme avant
nous avions le choix entre du paon ou du
cygne
si l'on fait les plus
avec de l'argent bien
qu'ils mangent du cygne
manger du sting c'était réservé pour les
grands pas bien sûr nous avons reproduit
cette idée résultat il faisait tellement
froid je suis rentré dans ma chambre et
bien la bataille de ba pas toilettes un
peu de chambres uniquement vraiment tout
comme avant en quoi
énormément
magali
je suis allé dans un hôtel de luxe
construits
encore bertrand
encore moi je dirais magali moins nantis
n'ont eux pas plus il co bah dites le
moi je fais dans les construit c'est bon
alors c'est moi chanoir savez j'avais
décidé jamais d'essayer pour une fois
d'aller dans un hôtel très chic et en
fait il n'était pas à pas du tout finie
c'était vraiment une catastrophe gelé
bernard sève l'extérieur était sublime
mais vraiment c'est est on est on est
rentrés donc l'accueil était fait on est
rentré dans la chambre et je peux dire
que là c'était vraiment un gros merdier
n'y avait pas de télé les prises
électricité était pas fini il y avait
pas de douche ah oui
c'était sous la porte tiens y'a pas de
lit
je suis redescendu j'ai dit que si moi
il ya un problème est ce que vous pouvez
me changer de chambre et c'est énorme on
vous a pas prévenu voilà l'hôtel baur ça
être un cinq étoiles magnifique le
problème c'est qu'il n'est pas terminée
jb oui mais quand même j'ai prié non
mais ne vous inquiétez pas et en fait je
ne fais pas d'autre endroit pour dormir
c'était la merde on est avec un pote et
je suis resté là bas et en fait on s'est
douchée en bas là où il y avait le
personnel c'était un gros merdier la
périphérie tu as payé le prix je n'ai
jamais été remboursés nahrawess
attention ouais mais bon ça reste un
souvenir c'est arriveront-ils c'était
aux antilles c'est comme çà mau motu
avoir mon airbnb bon airbnb était
infesté de cafards géants et volant jean
michel merle noir bertrand pacé toi ça
toutes les tares
et châteaux glace il fait ce qu à moi
j'irai
j'allais à miami avec ma meilleure amie
on aère bienne be on était trop contente
on était trop fraîches ont été dosés
partis en vacances je sais dit j'avais
de super décote super elle est partie
dans la salle de bains s'est mis à crier
mais j'ai dit mail avec 3 serial qu'elle
a donc vraiment un courriel
vraiment serré dernière
les patients ça va démarrer bientôt mais
j'ai vu sortir mais je vous jure que
c'est vrai un truc qui ressemblait à un
avion militaire je vous jure avec de
la sueur les murs le bien faire ne vole
pas il américain oui
[Applaudissements]
on est quand même resté là bas parce
qu'on avait l'occasion pour nana et la
marmotte à la nuit après le bonbon
super
les policiers ont envahi la villa où
j'étais hébergé ben collins a remis son
nom
oui c'est moi c'était il ya une dizaine
d'années les bonnes questions et j'ai
des potes qui m'a dit viens il on a loué
une maison à côté de barcelone vient je
veux c'est bien ce qu'ils avaient les
moyens et cdp maison brda merci au moins
20 km à l'intérieur des terres je n'ai
pas tellement l'intérêt quand tu m'as en
vacances et puis un jour les policiers
ont envahi et complètement la maison je
me suis rendu compte qu'en fait j'étais
tombé dans un repaire de brigands il
faisait des gains de l'ofa centre
marcellin et perpignan et il voulait que
la voiture il aurait permis mais si tu
te fais arrêter tu roules tu t'emmerdes
pas de façon paiera pas les pbx et il
voulait que je fasse des go-fast men
sera opposé le prix de 25 euros c'est
vrai chez impayés bien sûr j'appelle à
une personne qui avait loué c'est
incroyable je raconte dans le livre que
je mûris tous sortis s'appelait joseph
s est en effet très tôt prison des
voitures qui passaient ma petite rue eh
bien j'ai un jour il a dit plan qui tous
les flics aller schmidt a et je me suis
prêt à livrer les schmidt alors qu'à une
des voitures qui maintient il a senti il
m'a dit quand tu auras fait trois ans de
cavale tu reconnais tu les sentir à deux
kilomètres à la ronde mais avec qui part
en battant sa part espère de gandhi n'a
trafic avec des bagnoles volet
c'est quand est-ce que tu sors ton
bouquin
très bientôt
j'ai loué la même vie lacunes mais
je dirais plutôt magali
sébacées de leur maladie mais qui ont
les moyens
allez allez allez en bas de
décalage alors explique nous voyons
alors garé près tous les détails
alors qu'un des aspects c'est un
désastre alors allez-y
allemann
veyriras net j'ai loué là même qui la
contient une étude
la classe alors déjà montés sur jantes
et déjà on est sur un petit 150 me de la
semaine et j'ai trouvé son shampoing
pour la douche c'était vraiment le sien
suprise pour angelina jolie pendant une
semaine pendant mes vacances une semaine
donc le pdg d l'anecdote mais pas les
choix elle était toujours là le
champagne a dit le champion maintenant
la même ville raconte lina johnny si tu
enlèves vous êtes une arnaque aux
baraques depuis une star voilà qu'il ait
loué avant vous il m'a dit l'agent
immobilier je peux pas le deviner je
suis le remarquer pour tullow et en fait
non il y avait son shampoing j'ai
vérifié sur internet et tout c'était la
vraie marque de shampooing mais s'il
n'ya pas
le même sens
j'ai passé avec l'audi un palace cinq
étoiles alors à cette audi surclassé
c'est vrai que c'est la règle c'est la
divine la princesse
c'est la vie à vos calculs alors vous
allez encore vous [ __ ] de non non je
m'habille pas été tenues j'arrive dans
les jardins alors je vous dis fille
ludivine est très connue elle est très
venté s'entraîner
la police nationale est là et tout le
monde est au garde à vous
vous avez pas en vinyle évidemment on
dirait des gens n'en reviens pas déjà
alors du coup j'avais un budget assez
serré et je pars donc pour travailler
donc je me dis bon voila ma main je pars
dans un hôtel plutôt pas mal je réserve
une chambre vous savez sur les sites on
peut réserver des chambres à moindre
coût dans des beaux endroits et je
prends ça mais là la chance n'est pas
une chance c'est un truc de ouf c'était
cité en ruine c'était dégueulasse va
peut-être au même hôtel que moi el
cheikh c'était dégueulasse sauf qu'à la
différence quand j'allais me plaindre à
la réception
on m'a un peu reconnu
sécurité
ses qualités de
diviser vous êtes là non plus
c'est pas bien on sait de plus les yeux
szczesny ce pas un peu reconnu j'ai dit
que je ne pouvais pas parce qu'en plus
de travail et il fallait que je sois
super fraîche et tout et on m'a fait
passer dans une suite prévenir mieux lui
jure que c'est vrai et donc il ne suit
pas c'est d'après dans une suite à un
placement de suite 5 étoiles mais ça
mais dans quel pays c'est en guadeloupe
à
ses
voyages elle voyage gratuit rime
tout ça c'est vraiment une star l'avait
bien dit mais bien sûr je me suis
retrouvé dans un hôtel de paul cuisset
urgo donc ça s'est passé à berlin il est
à peu près dix ans j'étais avec berlin à
berlin une berline à
berlin petit budget et en effet on
trouve sur internet un hôtel avec
vraiment appris qui perd sympa on se dit
trop cool on va découvrir pas à pas nous
nous coûter grand chose on arrive dans
ce fameux hôtel qui a déjà plein de tags
un peu chelou je pénètre le
il soigne et bien sûr et là plein de
belles femmes avec des talons assises et
toupie je me dis mes pieds me regarde je
me dis je suis épuisé je mets fin je me
sens frais est en fait très rapidement
je comprends que c'est un hôtel de passe
et que ce sont des gens pour ses dires
des professionnels
des chambres à louer des chambres
s'étaient c'était des chambres toutes
les heures de repas officiels mais on
pouvait très bien comprendre que ces
femmes là il n'était pas pour gagner ce
intéressant dans l'histoire c'est que on
le sait vous vous êtes plutôt du côté
des hommes ah bah oui et vous me dites
que vous étiez dans un hôtel où vous
avez repéré des femmes non il n'y avait
pas ce qu'avec presque que des femmes
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui m'a mis la puce
à l'oreille des
talons de 12 cm tous ah bon mais en tout
cas n'empêche que les femmes mais elle a
le regard de sa
fille
qui part en vacances
tout ce boulot boulot
[Musique]
un peu chez ma mère à biarritz 7e ouais
bien sûr si jo bah oui c'est vrai que
mariage de mon fils en espagne après
biarritz alors vous foncez se rendre sur
mon île j'en avais en profiter ouais
bien sûr de toi qui par là nulle part
nulle part
[Rires]
alors oui les maladies tel aviv mais ça
va pas dans ta tête colas à vous aider
ou tel aviv à 13 jours j'avais plein la
tête super
c'est deckers vous aider à balmoral
voilà
sinon en belgique un peu aussi ce plat
pays qui est le mien
vous me donne aussi connu bien sûr du 10
au 21 ème temps que de lambeaux
forcément
presse oui oui on ne peut pas non pas
d'une chauvin t on va 3d de trois jours
mais moi ses débuts vous allez vous
croisez vous croisez
se faire une petite bise une petite
soirée de l'entretien pas propos de
d'hébergement il habitait chez moi de
l'anru ans et 6 mois alors non au départ
il m'a dit qu'un jour bédié je viens
et deux semaines trois semaines quatre
semaines
il restait six mois à la six mois six
mois vous êtes simple nourrit déjanté
logés blanchis vous êtes un homme il n'a
pas fait les courses mais non alors ça
jamais non ça c'est pas fait fin ce nom
et c'est maintenant à rien mais il m'a
offert un cadeau quand il est parti il
m'a offert un bon pour un week end
non faire un bond dans un hôtel à
deauville ouais ou g où j'avais une
villa merci le taux d'erreur
ce qui cause bien sûr réputé six mois
dans le viiième 400 mètres carrés ça
vaut bien un ticket restaurant la domine
on lui avait offert c'est ça l'amitié
mais bien sûr on ne court quand on aime
on compte pas que simplement c'est bien
sûr qu'est ce que j'aime comme jean et
vous madame je rentre mme bah oui
on retourne au ministère bah oui oui
bien si la présidence très bien
vous ce jeu reste à au pays basque à
saint jean il y en a tout mer et
montagne pourquoi pas personne n'est
d'accord
une virée parisienne tinevez je pense
qu'il va bosser un peu cet été